celle-là tout le monde me demande sur
les réseaux tiens raconte la cause là
c'est un petit garçon il va voir son
père il dit papa dis-moi pourquoi on a
une djellaba je sais pourquoi on est
dans le désert là j'ai la barre tu auras
pas beaucoup de choses ça va faire du
bien il est d'accord il dit mais papa
pourquoi on me dit des des chaussures
bizarres je sais pas des chaussures
bizarres ça c'est des babouches comme ça
quand tu marches dans le désert le sable
il rentre pas dans tes pieds il dit mais
papa pourquoi on met un truc là dis ça
s'appelle la chassia c'est contre le
soleil comme ça quand on est dans le
désert le soleil va pas nous taper il
dit pas papa puisque le si bien équipé
contre le désert qu'est-ce qu'on voit
argenté
[Applaudissements]